Bueno es un grupo de Facebook que se
creó en el año 2017 en él muchas
personas compartían ideas de extrema
derecha identitarias nacionalistas
contra los migrantes hablaban incluso de
atacar a los migrantes o de hacer
ataques en general incluso contra el
presidente Manuel macron entonces fue
creado este grupo por un jubilado de 66
años
y el justamente la policía recibe
informaciones de que este hombre
intentaba realizar un ataque en contra
del presidente él hablaba de un ataque
durante un baño de multitudes del
presidente no sé si acuerde esa gira y
itinerante Memorial que hizo el
presidente cuando se cumplieron los 100
años del armisticio de la Primera Guerra
Mundial Ellos pensaban hacer ese ataque
en el este del país este sujeto hablaba
de atacarlo con un cuchillo de cerámica
pues justamente no era detectado por los
detectores de metales entonces la
policía comenzó a seguir a este hombre
lo puso bajo escucha una semana después
lo detuvo con otras las personas en el
auto del sujeto se encontró un cuchillo
una Biblia y otro material de
supervivencia y en la casa de varios de
los detenidos armas y municiones